the sky is falling the sky is falling
see how these trees sway like one single
blob in Disney's Chicken Little compare
that to this tree in Encanto where each
individual Leaf moves realistically on
its own
in fact zoom out on Chicken Little and
you'll see just how little detail is in
the background compared to Disney's
newer features Chicken Little was
Disney's first foray into full 3D
animation so the worlds the studio could
create were a lot simpler but animated
worlds have evolved a lot since 2005 and
one film in particular kicked off a
whole new era of realistic environments
tangled tangled really represented to me
the film where we achieved the promise
of taking the artist degree that existed
at Disney Animation Studios and apply
that to the medium of cge to create the
world of Tangled or any 3D animated
World Disney has a dedicated
environments team whose job is to model
and develop the movie's backdrop based
on the concept designs the studio then
uses software programs to automatically
simulate the behavior of world elements
like plants water and lighting that
illuminates it all to fill up the
Whimsical forests of Tangled Disney
developed Special Tree modeling tools to
help the environments team lay down the
geometry for lots of trees all with a
specific fairy tale look that echoed the
flowing shapes of hand-drawn animation
and painting these new tree tools
included a program called Skeletor which
let artists and model 3D geometry on
certain hero trees like this one that
Rapunzel little swings from they also
built a new software called dendro which
let them art direct the growth of the
Whimsical trees and program the
direction and amplitude of wind in the
trees branches and leaves dendro also
helped calculate how branches should
grow according to environmental factors
like gravity and light and natural
obstacles
the storybook trees for Frozen were even
more stylized than Tangled inspired by
the unusual tree design in Sleeping
Beauty to create these highly specific
shapes and branching structures Disney
developed a full vegetation generator to
replace dendro called Bonsai with Bonsai
the studio could build a wide library of
trees bushes plants and foliage that
could be shared and reused across other
Disney Productions like big hero 6.
Bonsai came in handy for animated
vegetation like this in the film setting
of San Francisco the main challenge was
its fully Urban landscape which stood
apart from the organic environment seen
in earlier films involving many more
layers of objects movement and above all
lights Disney needed a way to render
complex lighting environments luckily
Disney Engineers were hard at work on a
powerful new renderer called Hyperion
which could produce densely packed
scenes with light bouncing around in
every direction handling several million
Rays at a time
this allowed the team to build a vibrant
City lit in some Shots by hundreds of
thousands of sources from Street lamps
to car headlights that was a big leap in
terms of complexity in terms of the
number of individual assets that we can
actually render in one scene
it also helped the filmmakers on Moana
capture the fanciful sense of scale they
wanted the name of moana's fictional
home means literally big island and
thanks to Hyperion the team could
produce sunlit shots at the beach where
water simulations with full surface
Reflections extended a quarter mile into
the distance and Village shots with
about 10 times the geometric complexity
of San Francisco the renderer also
powered over a hundred shots of the
monster taka illuminated by bright
streams of lava permeating through
massive smoke plumes to shape the
behavior of the molten lava Disney
updated its physically based simulator
Matterhorn originally developed for the
snow in Frozen Disney now expanded this
software to handle the more viscous
substance of lava along with other
natural Island materials like sand mud
and foam a scouting trip to Tahiti
helped Larry the head of environments
for Moana determine how each of the
film's over 60 species of vegetation
should Move With the Wind every minute
everything was moving so we knew we had
to do that in our movie like the fact
that coconut trees leaflets and Bows
should Sway With The Breeze while the
trunks themselves remain still for more
dramatic vegetation movement in the
tafiti healing sequence the effects team
created spreading texture maps of plant
growth you could almost claim that Moana
is probably the real progenesis of like
when we started to do really complex
animated vegetation at the studio of
course the star of this world was water
present in nearly every shot and in much
more complex forms than Disney had ever
produced including waves of all sizes
breaking in specific patterns on the
sand and wreath so Disney developed a
new engine called Splash which could
simulate waves running crashing and
breaking and create secondary effects
like boat wigs but while the water in
Moana looks warm crystal clear and
inviting the dark sea and Frozen 2 had
to be rough dark and stormy to convey
the threats facing Elsa as she embarks
on her Quest and I feel like we just
continually stand on our own shoulders
with the films that come before us so
creating the waves in Frozen 2 that
would have been a whole different
adventure for us if Moana hadn't come
before that
so the team shot reference footage in
parts of the southern California coast
where the waves break especially hard
they then used a set of equations to
model the motion of the dark sea waves
experimenting with different values for
variables like amplitude and ocean floor
depth until they got waves that were
three to four times Elsa's size the
artists then added more foam and spin
drift Mist to capture the rough
churned-up nature of the dark sea but
the dark sea only marks one stage in
Elsa's Quest most of the film takes
place in another entirely new setting
the Enchanted Forest far from Arendelle
just as the waves had to Tower over Elsa
making her look small many of the shots
in the forest are framed extra wide to
emphasize the character's isolation
which also puts more of the world on
display and since the characters spend
so much time in this setting Disney had
to take its Forest population
capabilities up a notch so it developed
a new vegetation placement tool or
droplet designed as an interactive Rush
droplet let artists paint down scale and
reposition vegetation in an art-directed
way giving them control over the flow
and style of the forest as a whole the
artists had to paint not only the canopy
but also the ground cover in the
saturated colors of autumn in contrast
to the snow blanketed grounds of the
first movie
luckily they could use Bonsai from
Frozen 1 to manipulate the color of the
leaves on the forest floor and make the
forest look striking not just in
overhead shots but from every angle this
forest is beautiful
since the snow has melted in Arendelle
the team had to render its buildings in
much higher detail increasing the
texture resolution this visual richness
was equally necessary for the forest Dam
where surface textures helped tell the
backstory the filmmakers decided that
King runard's workers would have to cut
the Stone from the surrounding Fjord
walls and assemble each block by hand to
reinforce this idea artists sculpted in
high level detail little imperfections
on all the surfaces and used texture
software to create subtle material
variation like these uniquely rotated
cut marks on each block and to show that
34 years had passed since its
Construction Artists use droplet to
paint hundreds of thousands of
iterations of moss grass and mulch
Disney continued to improve that
vegetation pipeline for Raya and The
Last Dragon but the major Focus was this
the atmospherics of the Southeast Asian
settings these regions tend to be dense
with water and moisture so the
environment's called for a lot of
volume-based elements like Morning Mist
and ground fog traditionally that work
would fall on the effects department but
in Raya instead of having the effects
Department create atmospheric elements
on a per shot basis Disney created these
elements in pre-production and put them
into an extensive Library later as
lighting artists were lighting a shot
they could pull from that library and
compose the atmospherics into it without
having to request new assets from the
effects Department every time this gave
the lighters more flexibility over
complex atmospheric setups and more
freedom to express the emotional story
in each scene dust and smoke signified
moments of conflict and misgivings while
trusting moments between characters were
heavier on water elements like mist and
steam just as rya's Southeast Asian
setting defined its World elements in
condos Colombian setting called for a
lush jungle surrounding the madrigals
village and this environment it had to
be in motion like we'd see more of later
on with Strange World which was in
production at the same time as in
content specifically Isabella's song is
brought to life by the whole animated
environment with these flowering plants
growing in sync with the music but that
Dynamic environment work was done mostly
by hand each artist had to go into each
and every shot of that sequence was a
beautiful sequence and bring in custom
rigs that allowed them to do the growth
for those plants Disney had to figure
out a way to do that work in advance for
Strange World which more than any other
Disney animated environment featured a
lot of moving Parts literally
it's beautiful elements like these
plants acted as background characters
and part of the environment at the same
time cassette the whole landscape in
motion the studio created an entirely
new role animated environment supervisor
that role has me interacting with almost
every Department in the studio certainly
with the production environments team to
ensure that the assets that they're
building will be animatable and then
that would move towards effects and
character animation to provide animation
for those plants kind of varying and
moving plants through the whole pipeline
one shot at a Time Disney also adjusted
its pipeline so that Ben's team could
fine-tune the environment's movement
earlier on in the process new to this
show was the opportunity to say that
plant right there is moving a little too
much or it's just a little too crazy to
make sure that we were handing off the
plants in in the environment in its best
state before it hit the really render
intensive departments such as effects
and lighting where things start to get a
little bit harder to change so we would
do the growing in advance and then when
shots came we would place that animation
in so all of the work was front loaded
for a strange World which allowed us to
do many hundreds more shots that Encanto
did the environments in this movie
weren't just dynamic they were some of
the largest ever created at Disney
animation with some stretching two and a
half miles wide so large that the team
needed to expand its computing power
after Peak I think there was a shot with
20 or 30 million Blades of alien grass
convey the strange world's vastness the
lighting team made heavy use of
atmospheric elements like those used for
Raya adding clouds and ground fog to
create a sense of depth and scale these
expansive sets lent themselves to wider
camera lenses the camera and layout team
could use controls to adjust the lens
Distortion so whenever they wanted a
shot to feel off-kilter and well strange
they could dial up the Distortion effect
a decision always driven by the story
context of the scene it all comes
together with editing which gives the
audience space to take in the
environment and sound design which helps
communicate the character of the space
because you know it doesn't have a face
it can't communicate that way but it can
communicate through sound it's squishy
it breathes I make sure that there's an
intentional personality behind every
little sound that the plants make as
they breathe in or breathe out or
unplate now that Disney's built such a
powerful tool set for living breathing
Worlds the team has to step it back
sometimes especially since unlike live
action filmmakers they're creating these
worlds from the ground up and feature
animation sort of the skies the limit
and you can easily put more in than you
need you're looking for that Perfect
Blend of organic fascinating texture in
the background not so much that it's
going to take away from what the
characters are doing and what the
characters are saying after all Disney
builds worlds to service the story not
the other way around for the same reason
it doesn't stick to any house style for
World design instead tailoring each
world to its story needs just contrast
the details of the castles entangled and
Frozen Rapunzel's tower the wooden beams
there isn't a straight game anywhere
everything's handcrafted hand hewn
everything's got a slight twist and an
organic feel to it riffing off of the
design principles that applied to Snow
White and Pinocchio when you look at the
Interiors of the castle and Frozen we do
have a lot of very straight rigid line
and that's of course all done to support
what we're saying about those
environments oh this is for royalty okay
they were getting the best Craftsman who
could make the straightest line and
really everything needs to go through
that level of rigor and discussion those
decisions on Strange World struck a
balance between making the landscape
feel imaginative and unexpected while
retaining the story first principle that
made the classic Disney movie is so
beloved
foreign
[Music]